well, it
detected a fire in a
commercial complex on picos road and star avenue
that the firefighters were able to put out
quickly
hello how are you, greets you natale lancelot
and with your brief informative today it is not
now in Spanish no one was injured but
the fire reached other
nearby businesses  and generated several
structural damages the cause of this incident is
still under investigation and the popular
singer of him had to postpone her
shows in las vegas they were going to start
on friday night at the get
inside the cistercian pallais she posted
a video on her networks  social media where it
said that half of the work team had
contracted the cover and they could not put together and
finish the show there are no
rescheduled dates so far but yes
years said that the show will be
extraordinary once they can
carry it out the shortage of
supplies could force some
restaurants in the valley to have to
change their - that's right several places are
having problems to maintain and  you are
special ingredients in their kitchens
the shortage of staff is also
causing other problems such as
delays in food shipments some
choose to raise prices while
others vary their menus and now we turn
to the weather forecast we will have another
day of pleasant temperatures with
highs  in the 60 degrees however
by Saturday there will be some breezes
around the valley that will calm down on
Sunday they will not last long we will
delight ourselves again with a lot of sun for
next week beautiful day I will greet you
lanzelotti with an informative envelope from and
we now in Spanish
[Music]